how can these families continue to honor
these deaths
by keeping the dreams of these children
and teachers alive
again how can a loss of these lives
matter it seems that something is
different uvalde texas is where i was
born
uvalde is where i learned responsible
gun ownership
now you've already called me on may 24th
when i learned the news of this
devastating tragedy actor and you all
day native matthew mcconaughey making a
passionate plea for gun control at the
white house press briefing room today
speaking to reporters about the victims
of the mass shooting at rob elementary
school after meeting with their families
and calling on lawmakers to act
we need to invest in mental health care
we need safer schools
we need to restrain sensationalized
media coverage
we need to restore our family values
we need to restore
our american values
and
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
we need to raise the minimum wage to
purchase an ar-15 rifle
221
we need a waiting period for those
rifles we need red flag laws and
consequences for those who abuse them
responsible gun owners
are fed up
with the second amendment being abused
and hijacked by some deranged
individuals
the actor also imploring congress to
find some middle grounds
we got to get some real courage
and honor our immortal obligations
instead of our party affiliations enough
with the counter punching
enough of the invalidation of the other
side
let's come to the common table that
represents
the american people find a middle ground
the place where most of us americans
live
anyway all right tulsi what do you think
the impact
of matthew mcconaughey showing up to the
briefing room will be if anything
oh first i've i've gotten to know
matthew and as his wife and and family
and
he's a sincere person you know he
genuinely cares about our country cares
about the american people and so i think
this message was delivered in that
in that spirit and i hope it's received
in that way as well and he's i
completely agree we do have to come
together as a country and i think there
is common ground that can be had
where i think we all want to make sure
that criminals and those who shouldn't
have their hands on guns don't and that
we do not in any way undermine our
second amendment rights the the those
law-abiding american citizens who own
guns should not see their guns taken
away
judge do you think the things that he
laid out just now
i think raising it to 21 getting rid of
sensationalized media coverage red flag
laws family values do you think those
are kind of a middle ground in the
united states
absolutely and i think it was delivered
brilliantly what he did was he had both
the intellectual as well as the
emotional pieces combined he did it in a
way and i questioned what he was doing
in the white house briefing room i
really did
but then i realized he did it better
than anyone from congress or certainly
the president of the united states could
do
and he presented things to make everyone
feel that they were vested in this and i
think he embarrassed congress when he
said you know what there's no reason why
we can't restore family values american
values responsible gun ownership he
protected the second amendment he
recognized that mental health is an
issue he was brilliant he or he was
absolutely brilliant and by the way when
he talked about red flag which is a
difficult pill to swallow for a lot of
people he talked about consequences to
those who abuse it so if you claim
someone is doing something and you're
wrong you do it out of viciousness you
need to be prosecuted yeah you could
just drop a dime on someone you hated
just to
have them investigated and take their
guns away i'm going to do that to you
first you would you would the first guy
i have a step ahead of you though i know
i know
somebody's waiting outside greg yes
you know but the thing is i did not see
that as anything about gun control i saw
that as about the united states i felt
that he had stepped back and it goes
back to the what we've been saying
you've heard all of those things here at
this table about a multifaceted approach
but there's a half of the country or
half of the people they don't listen to
us because of course we're in our silos
and he has the benefit of being outside
the silos he's uh he's untethered to any
ideology you can't guess which way he's
zigging or zagging half the time and
when he talks about middle ground he's
coming from a position of good faith
he's persuading as somebody who can
uh appease appeal to both sides i mean
he actually went
he did the homework he went out and
actually talked to both sides and a lot
of people don't do that anymore so that
was i thought that was interesting but
it just it wasn't about gun control he
was showing how all of these things are
kind of interconnected and when he said
those two things that you know popped
out to you know when he said restrained
sentencing media coverage okay he's
speaking my language because that's all
i talk about but it's combined with the
restoring of family values he's
basically saying that like we're
creating broken kids right and then they
are being amplified by a broken media
and it these things all come together
and he also talked about securing
schools that's another part of it so i
think like he is able to do something
that
like we could talk about this forever
and we're only speaking to the choir he
can bounce from church to church and
people pretty much go oh he's a movie
star he's a movie star but he's not he's
rare and that he actually like he's not
like a guy who tweets on twitter or
something when it happens like you can
tell hopes and prayers to go to hell he
actually goes does the homework and
that's why you can trust him right see
the thing is one thing he said when he
said uh and i'll shut up he was talking
about
this is it was a great twist he was
tired of the second amendment being
hijacked by like mad men that was a nice
twist because you expected to say you
know gun control freaks or right-wing
extremists he was talking about the
madman that hadn't been done yet but he
he didn't address the challenge but it's
in there
that um
the other side looks at all gun owners
the same and that's what creates the
mistrust
that we're all painted as rednecks in
the back of pickup truck trucks trailing
people around vigilantes what he was
saying is
overwhelming majority of gun owners are
responsible gun owners and they're just
as ticked either very clever smart move
and that the republicans should take
that
everything he said
build a bill and beat the democrats if
you want to get political about it yeah
maybe tomorrow he'll come out and do a
press briefing on gas
[Laughter]
is so prices so interesting like
sometimes
when you i agree with everything that
you've said
sometimes you need a different messenger
and because everybody all the things
that are going to be said on this have
been said people are tuning out the
president uh even the press secretary
right so she
well she it is like she gets she she
couldn't deliver a message like that but
one that you mentioned how genuine he is
and so that authenticity comes through
and he also he's talking about his
hometown yeah and he's talked he knows
those people it's it's like when when
california first started going downhill
and it was like super personal to you
like you know that and or like on the
criminal justice system are you for you
in the military for me like with
ranchers and farmers jesse in his hair i
was trying to think of one for him and i
i would say though with children right
like when you talk like so passionately
about children especially so if you have
somebody who
in matthew mcconaughey can come out and
say okay here's my personal experience
and i was thinking of peggy noonan's
piece on saturday in the wall street
journal the very end line she said
i've never known a country so in need of
a hero not saying that matthew
mcconaughey is a hero but it does make
you realize that you need somebody who
can say all right we know that there's a
vast center
and we know that they feel like they are
not being heard and they don't have a
voice because there are extremes on both
sides that are getting most of the media
attention so it's very it's very
interesting and i think that the white
house made a really good decision either
by inviting him or maybe accepting his
request yeah i don't know how exactly
that happened but it was it was a good
thing to do by the way um how did you
meet matthew mcconaughey what was that
like
um it was great i had dinner with with
him and his wife and kids and it was it
was really special they were out in
hawaii and
wonderful family traditions everyone
going around the table and saying what
are you grateful for the kids and
they surf a lot the kids love to surf
and so they spend they spend a bit of
time on hawaii please make note of how
she says hawaii
i was gonna ask who paid
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now